okay this might be my last morning
thought because i i gotta get going to
the airport soon picking up my little
sister someone commented and asked what
sister it was
oh that's my four sisters um
she's my second youngest
and she's 17. i'm 25 so there's a little
age gap she's my little babysitter
anyways super normal not even that
excited at all i have a life um
anyways okay next morning thought
do people change
no
this is not backed up by any
studies
any data
but in my experience
i don't think most people do
not
like people people have patterns okay of
behavior and people have
like habits
that they always like
i don't want to say always revert back
back to there's exceptions but for the
most part any person i know that like
has said or they've changed or gone
through like a life-altering experience
or whatever
they always go back to that habit like
two three years later and i'll use
myself i'll use myself as a goddamn
example okay
in college guys look
your girl
binge drinker
okay i
bro like
i drank a lot it was not cute it was not
cute at all
i'm just like i'm very extroverted i'm
social i i enjoy events okay
but
i would have a little too much fun you
know like oh my god i would just get so
drunk it was not cute i actually got
paid to drink at one point that's enough
that's a story for a different day um
anyways
what
i found is that
i can go like nowadays
i like i barely ever drink i drink a
couple times a year i just say i don't
drink cause it's like easier
but even with that i always still have
that urge inside of me that like wants
to drink like there's a part of me
there's a small part of me that i try
every day to kill
that wants to get effed up that wants to
get like like stupid drunk like
literally like because i used to love
doing it and i know the problems that
come with it i know the consequences of
those decisions and i changed my
behavior around like 21 22 i'm 25 now
and it took me so much work
to get to that point i moved cities to
get away from like the environment first
i
i would like do challenges in my head of
how long i could go without drinking
like at first i kept it under like three
drinks to do like i slowly weave myself
up
and i know how much work goes into like
trying to change and like most people
don't do it
and that was a habit i only had for like
three four years of my life like it
wasn't even that long
and same with my eating habits like i
have been working for years i'm finally
having success but guys i've been trying
to lose weight since i was 20.
probably before that
little to no success like
i say as i drink a mocha
most people
are good doing what they've always done
like the biggest predictor of past
behavior future behavior is past
behavior
and
yeah i don't really think most people
change and oftentimes when i see people
like
wolf of wall street type guy where he's
like oh i've changed i'm a new person
i'm like did you
did you really
because i guarantee like he just seems
shady
but i'd love to have you on my podcast
sir
but i do really think
if that guy didn't have the potential
consequence of like his whole brand
coming down like he wouldn't do the same
shady [ __ ] again
come on come on
um so i don't know be wary of people
that tell you they're gonna change
because i
in my experience like most people their
core is kind of like who they are
and if they do change they got to change
out but like the core like who they are
as a person
there's only so much you can do you
can't run from yourself
so
maybe maybe this is my last morning
thought until i think of another but
comment below what you would like my
opinions on
for my next morning thought